good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
and i'm proud to welcome you to this
edition of our 2021-2022
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational health institute of
virginia the uva brain institute the
college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from
the national institutes of general
medical sciences this year's theme is
ethical challenges of artificial
intelligence in biomedicine where we
enjoy presentations on fridays from
leading thinkers about the promise
opportunities and hurdles associated
with ai applications in the biomedical
sciences selected participants in our
biomedical data science innovation lab
program will leverage these
presentations as vital material for our
culminating in-person grant project
development workshop to take place here
in historic charlottesville virginia
this coming june today i am delighted to
welcome our speaker dr donna chen from
here at the university of virginia
donna went to the school of medicine at
the university of california san
francisco and the school of public
health at the university of california
berkeley for her medical education and
her public health education respectively
she received her residency training at
the sakai in psychiatry at columbia
university and new york state
psychiatric institute where she um once
served as chief resident she has also
served as associate scientific editor
and scientific consultant for the
surgeon general's report mental health
culture race and ethnicity
uh she worked at the spend some time at
the national institutes of health where
she received specialty training in
consultation liaison psychiatry and
completed a post-doctoral fellow in
fellowship excuse me in research ethics
in 2003 as an assistant professor she
returned to the university of virginia
to work with the department of health
evaluation sciences and the department
of psychiatric medicine here she is the
director of the ethics in education um
uh excuse me let me get this right the
center for health humanities and ethics
the chhe
and his associate professor in the
department of public health sciences and
the department of psychiatry
she is an award-winning educator and
directs the ethics education across
four-year medical education program and
she's the founding director of chhe's
fusion lab
leveraging her formal training in ethics
medicine psychiatry and public health
research she's conducted empirical or
conceptual ethics research as a
co-investigator or consultant for a
number of multi-site national
international studies served as an
ethics expert on a number of different
nih
panels
and
other professional activities she
currently serves on the steering
committee for the national national
clinical research ethics consultation
collaborative and chairs the research
ethics consultation affinity group for
the american society for bioethics and
humanities but most importantly out of
all those credentials we are pleased to
have donna be one of our
2021-2022 biomedical data science
innovation lab mentors very important
credential looks really good on the cv
donna
in continuing the the our biomedical
data science seminar series theme for
this year donna's lecture today is
entitled a beginner's mind donna will be
discussing ai from a beginner's point of
view
donna currently considers herself a
beginner and having paid scholarly
attention to ai until up till now yet
feeling the call to help craft an ai
story we can all live with her talk
today affords her a unique opportunity
to embrace her positionality as an
actual beginner in this intellectual
space that said even when not a beginner
the capacity to embrace a beginner's
mind to be open and curious and listen
actively is an essential professional
skill and donna will
tell us how she uses this daily to meet
others where they are as a physician a
researcher educator and ethics
consultant and she brings all those uh
skills together today in her talk and as
always we are streaming this lecture
live and for reporting via youtube if
you are watching on youtube thank you
very very much for joining us and also
our specially selected
2021-2022 biomedical data science
innovation lab participants are very
strongly encouraged to submit any
questions for donna via the chat feature
and the zoom sessions i will synthesize
these questions and ask them on your
behalf during the last 10 minutes or so
of the lecture and with that donna
welcome thank you so very very much for
uh joining us and we really look forward
to your lecture
thank you jack and uh welcome everybody
it's a pleasure to be able to talk with
you guys today
um first i wanted to acknowledge that um
the traditional custodians of the land
that uva is on the monacon people or the
monacan nation
um so as as jack said um i really am
embracing my positionality as a beginner
and so you know this is kind of how i
see myself in terms of ai and and ethics
in of ai et cetera
um and this is also how i see myself
when i try to think about
going any further than um hearing other
people talk about it but
this opportunity i decided was the time
to actually
go out of that little room into the um
wider outdoors i wanted to learn a new
language the ai language
machine learning and all of that
and i also realized this was an
opportunity to embrace the idea
that you know we don't know
why we're doing something and we don't
know why we're doing something new but
when we look backwards it'll all make
sense
and so
i started out with thinking well what
actually
do i know about ai
what do most doctors know about ai what
do i as a medical educator
need to start thinking about what our
students need to know about artificial
intelligence
um and of course it there's a lot um one
is that there's big data
and it's not only data that comes from
medical records and
research articles right we're moving
into the era of the internet of things
so our patients and probably we as
health care providers will have will be
connected to the internet and
um that's something that i don't know
that that
i don't know if any school is teaching
this medical school um but it is
something that we're going to have to
start paying attention to because a lot
of data is going to be coming in through
these different devices
people me included are going to have all
sorts of questions about privacy and
other protections that we will have as
people when this starts to happen
and then of course there's robots
avatars and cyborgs which are even more
interesting not more interesting but
for me and for this talk today they're
more interesting
um
and of course again going back to
thinking about um
the medical students the learners and um
all of us
healthcare providers um
we need to figure out how to incorporate
this learning and
these new ways of knowing
into our professional identities as
physicians
um and that's something that is actually
um i'm starting to get excited by that
idea instead of scared by that idea
so today i have three
um kind of inquiry inspired story lines
that i'm going to try to
draw together in the time that i have
and hopefully draw you into the story
lines as well
in order to answer some of the questions
that come from these stories
so the first one of course starts with
ibm's watson
and this is the whole the story of how
do we use predictive analytics to help
to help all of us actually
provide better care
so for those of you who don't know ibm
watson's story i'm going to tell it very
quickly and i'm probably going to get
many or all of the details wrong but
it's easy to find on the internet
so
watson debuted publicly
um
in
february of 2011 by winning
or beating two of the the best jeopardy
players
um this is the actual win i think
and
soon after that uh watson went to
medical school
or actually probably had been in medical
school
and shortly after that got got watson
got his i guess first
job
as a as a i guess health healthcare
consultant
so how did watson work
well
um watson obviously was an ai um with
decision analytics and again i'm a
beginner here so i'm going to get the
terminology wrong
and if anyone wants to help me with the
terminology that would be awesome
but what what the
clinicians did was they had a they had a
patient that they had some questions
about and so they would
you know
put in their question
hit the ask ask watson button
and watson would scroll through the
medical records confirm things find
things that maybe the clinician didn't
know about
and then provide
some treatment recommendations
for the clinician
along with some
articles that backed it up and some
statistics about the different
treatments
so
this
program was rolled out to a lot of
different institutions and a lot of
different countries
um
and it was
in some i think some of the institutions
talked about how it was actually a
really helpful
kind of marketing for them or status for
them to to be able to say that they were
that watson was helping them
um
unfortunately the story goes and i have
done none of this research myself this
is all research that i
got from articles or off the internet
um so take that for what it's worth
um but uh mr ross
from stat has been doing a lot of work
in this space and
what they uncovered what he i think
uncovered with his team
was that um there were there were and
and people were saying this but
but there were a lot of concerns
actually with what watson was
recommending
um and and
it was
clear
that the company ibm
had internal documents knew what some of
these concerns were
and yet their marketing their pr
remained
disconnected from what some of the
concerns were
in part it stemmed from the fact that
they were
promoting themselves as using more of a
machine learning
uh
technology
when in fact they were
inputting synthesized cases from
memorial sloan kettering the experts at
memorial sloan kettering i think i don't
know exactly why but i think they just
they it was too difficult actually the
healthcare space was too difficult to to
do machine learning at that time
um so it might have been a bit of a
hybrid
um
so
the story of watson is that it it
had this he made this huge splash when
it was announced and then it basically
deteriorated and
earlier this year um they kind of sold
off pizza pieces of watson um for for
its spare parts and the main concern the
main i think story here is that it
failed to live up to its hype the
marketing
the marketing and the actual capacity
were somehow disconnected
um
oops that's not what i wanted yeah this
is what i wanted um and you know the
this happens a lot actually when you
have
corporations or companies
um
working in the healthcare space without
really
i guess identifying with some of the
ethics that both
providers and patients expect right they
expect
that whatever is
um
used to augment
the
decision-making here or to replace the
decision-making has been vetted and is
considered safe and effective
and of course some of that's regulated
but a lot of a lot of the new
technologies are not yet regulated
and a lot of the training programs um
don't actually you know we're sometimes
we're taught to fake it
fake it till we make it um
and
so
the idea that you can kind of market
yourself in a way that might not be
necessarily 100 consistent with with the
research that you have maybe or maybe
haven't not done
um
is a is is a problem in many
areas many areas of um
many of the disciplines when people are
working in an interdisciplinary space
the ethics that people are taught within
their own disciplines
is robust
usually robust
but not always across disciplines and
that's not something that people always
think about
so hold that thought of the idea that
marketing sometimes gets ahead of the
actual data
because now we're going to move to covid
now the coveted story as everyone knows
has been rough and it it was rough here
in virginia it was rough everywhere
um
it was rough for the ethics and ethics
consultants too
and if if you read the newspaper or read
or read anything really right you'll you
will have seen
just
the
huge amount of um discussion and concern
about
the ways that we were trying to make
decisions that the different priorities
we were we were making
the different choices we were making
even what got onto the to the table to
be discussed
um
things were happening so quickly that
for all of us we
didn't always really have good grounding
in what we were trying to do
resources were abundant everyone had
collected resources to offer for for
people who are
charged with decision making
um including in the data space right
around privacy
power bias some of these articles are
from after that time period but a lot of
the questions were
discovered pretty quickly
but for patients and front line
clinicians help with predicting who was
at the highest risk of clinical
deterioration in the near term was the
most important thing i mean there are
obviously other important things right
but this was a super important thing
and um you know we
institutions and individuals were
starting to need to come up with um
triage triage algorithms
if we were going to need to to really
ration care
which
we don't
usually need to do
and so this was this was really really
difficult
and a lot of people got involved at uva
we got we had huge committees that would
kind of bring stuff to the table
community members that were involved
with some of these discussions
everyone came up with an algorithm
which you know did or didn't work
borrowed from everybody else in some
ways it was really great there was a lot
of community a lot of sharing in this in
this time period
interestingly for me when i was
looking around and
kind of exploring what was happening for
this talk i discovered an algorithm that
i had not heard of before and this was
an algorithm that epic
our medical record we use epic so i was
super surprised that i had not heard
about this particular algorithm um but
it's probably because we have experts
here who are working in this space and
so we didn't we didn't need epic's
algorithm we had our own experts and you
um those of you who heard um dr randall
mormon earlier would he was the one
who's been doing this for us
um he and his his um colleagues and his
students
but i still was surprised that i hadn't
heard of it
um
and i was also
surprised and i guess
pleasantly surprised when i
learned that the epics algorithm because
i was starting to wonder right
why were we so
why didn't we just use epic right why
don't we just use epic's algorithm every
a hundred other hospitals are using
epics algorithm
well it turns out
that epic actually released its
algorithm before it tested it
and um
it was
starting
to make
um
poor decisions
and because it was proprietary
the clinicians who were starting to
become concerned the institutions that
were starting to become concerned
weren't actually allowed to evaluate
the algorithms and to look kind of under
the hood
even if they did right they may not have
been able to figure out exactly what was
going on that's one of the difficulties
with
machine learning algorithms
uh nevertheless because it was
proprietary they weren't able to and and
when they started to look into the data
they realized that there actually
weren't that that many evaluations
independent evaluations of this
algorithm
when there was finally an external
validation of this algorithm that was
published just last year
it turned out that there were
it
did
much worse than they were saying that it
did so than what their marketers were
saying
um
but it also did worse than the
clinicians themselves and here's just
one example um
of what some of the problems were
so
epic plus and this is i borrowed from
professor gary smith because i thought
he did it so nicely
epic plus meant that epic
tagged that patient as
having
a high risk for sepsis
and
these folks at michigan ran this on on
some some of their own patients
um so epic tagged
this many people as
a high risk for sepsis
but only
this many
ended up becoming septic
and so there were
88
of the
alarms were false alarms
on the flip side
this many people ended up developing
sepsis
and only this many of them
were flagged
so they missed 67 percent
of sepsis and again
this was was
worse than the institution and the
clinicians did on their own without um
without this algorithm
uh
so this is just some of the
promotion from that
to make
matters
worse or even more complicated
it turns out that that algorithm had
been bundled i think had been bundled in
with um that that year's
um
epic honor roll
which means that and if for institutions
that make it to the epic honor roll they
get
i guess financial prize or a financial
reward
so
the institutions who adopted it
it was
being
it was as if they were being paid to
adopt this
algorithm um at least that's what people
are saying now that they know the full
story
um which makes it even uh kind of worse
in some ways
so these are again just the stories like
that so that the thought that you were
holding right so
this happens a lot it happens
you know it happens currently
um it's definitely something that we i
think as a society
and i think two weeks ago professor
trotter also mentioned this right the
norms of health care the norms of
science and the norms of business
diverge in many ways
and there are people working in that
that
space right healthcare and business
ethics and trying to to get that and
research ethics trying to get all those
um talking to one another
um
but it's still something i think we need
to really be careful about this was one
uh
one person's suggestion was you know if
you're going to do this work you really
need to have an institutional review
board which is the which is the board
that reviews
research before it it's allowed to go
forward
there is no board right now that really
has
um
[Music]
there probably are some most don't have
the expertise needed to evaluate
our ai kinds of things machine learning
kinds of things
so we're we think that we're out of at
least the fourth wave or fifth wave of
this pandemic but you know when when it
comes around again we're still going to
need to be making these decisions
um and we ideally would have algorithms
that have been
tested and vetted and that we know work
one of the problems though right is that
these algorithms appear to deteriorate
over time
um which in some ways when i mean those
of you who work in this area probably
know this already it was
was it something i had thought about
but when i did it it makes sense
um
what it reminded me of is is something
that i carry with me back from my kind
of my public health days
um and that's that the if your algorithm
is built just on patients either in the
hospital
oops my little boxes are off but they're
either in the hospital or for receiving
care from the medical system which is
where all of our medical records come
from right
you're only actually
getting information about
this number of people
of the thousand that exist in the
community
so no matter what as people come in and
out of the hospital right they're going
to be
different people
the illness trends change over time
insurance changes over time everything
changes over time and so
right why would we think that an
algorithm that was developed a static
algorithm would continue to work unless
built into it was a very robust way of
correcting itself and
data
up-to-date data were available in order
for it to correct itself
there's also
a lot of work being done right now to
figure out how do we
how do we make the algorithms more fair
when we think about the broader
population
um the public health and and
population health um kinds of thinking
being brought into this
so not just hospital-based not just
medical system based
and also right i think we all now are
comfortable with the idea that our
algorithms are biased and so
we need to pay close attention to how we
can
combat that
as we move towards the
my guess is the need for
uh research to be done on algorithms i
know this is a super messy slide
but the um
this set of studies was um
uh back in 2000 it's called it's a
parachute series which is uh most i
think most healthcare providers know
about this
uh but there was a a
tongue-in-cheek study published back in
2003
that basically said we have no good
studies
that show that parachutes work
so therefore it's not evidence-based and
you don't need to use them
or we should do a good study right so
that's this set
and so in 2018
some researchers actually actually took
them up on that challenge
and um did do a study
and they concluded that you didn't need
a parachute
so in a randomized control trial
um
so read these studies they're hilarious
but i think the take-home message is
that studies can be designed
to find what you want and so you also
need to be very careful about how you're
designing your study who you're
enrolling in your study in order to make
it um both address a question that you
that you're truly interested in
and
generalizable to the group of people to
the population who actually need the
information
uh there have just this year last year i
think
some guidelines now for how to do a
clinical trial that includes ai both in
terms of the protocol and the
publication
so know that those are out there
and as you move through
this area engage many people
in designing your study and thinking
about what it is we should be studying
um google has has a
effort that i was interested to learn
about um
right and they include a whole bunch of
different disciplines and also
kind of the community of the general
public
um and this was a study that i was
involved in
many many years ago that was very
community based
led by a community leader loretta jones
who
has since passed away but she had she
was somebody who was very inspirational
to me
in
the kind of work that i do and this was
a study looking at
depression in
central los angeles
one of the things that i remember most
about
this from this study was a mom
saying that
um
she was realizing that she would rather
have her son
spend time in jail for drug use charges
than to be labeled as depressed
and that was just such a huge
eye-opening statement
to hear that
and to realize at the time and still how
stigmatized
mental health issues can be
anyway moving on quickly because i know
i'm going to run out of time robots
right robot dogs in the hospital during
covid were absolutely acceptable and
they did a study to show that
uh so now moving to some of the mental
health stories
the the stories that i chose to tell
have to do with
um virtual mental health visits
starting from
the virtual reality apps
i'm not going to have that i'm not going
to have us listen to that one
but this one's actually an avatar
and it
she
monitors a ton i don't remember how many
like 50 different parameters
on the
person she's working with
um their face the activity where they're
gazing with the tone of their voice
where they're yeah where their eyes are
going
in order to
help her decide her next statement
so this i am going to have you listen to
is it uncomfortable for you to talk
about this
um yeah it is uh i
i hadn't really thought about that
um
so that's oops sorry um
so that's that she
was pre-programmed
and now
that we have gpt-3
um
people are starting to explore well what
would gpt-3 do in terms of um
serving as a as a
therapist really or a counselor or an
interim
counselor
gpt-3 for those who don't know about it
um and this is going to be super
simplistic
um but it's a language program
that uses natural language programming
to determine
what that what the next word in this in
a sentence or a phrase might be
so
if gbt3 was asked
how was your day today gbt3 would
respond
with what the next word which is my and
that it would incorporate that and the
next word would be day
until it
constructed this sentence it doesn't
always construct the same sentence but
that is how it goes about constructing
the sentence and gpt-3
was
trained on
basically the internet or something like
that
so i'm going to show you an another
little clip
from um
alan thompson who has like 50 clips on
the internet um of
him having a conversation with lita who
is a
avatar that he created through
synesthesia
and
the conversation is a gpt-3 driven
conversation and in this clip they're
actually talking about gpt4 which is
going to be the next
rendition of this particular algorithm
program
later there's a bit of talk about your
next iteration from open ai and it's
gonna be impressively huge
thank you
i am very excited about it and i think
we've come up with a great idea to make
the next iteration even better
100
trillion
parameters is roughly the same as the
number of synapses connections between
neurons in the human brain
that's a lot of synapses
the human brain has about 100 billion
neurons
gpt4 is also going to be over 500 times
larger and smarter than you
gpt4 will be able to understand human
speech and respond to it
all of that will be amazing
i think so too
it's bordering on
unimaginable
professor ray kurzweil said something
like that at the beginning of the 21st
century
that the accelerating pace of change
would go beyond human imagination
as we approach the date of singularity
and as we observe the accelerating pace
of change i expect that some will
question our ability to cope
we will be so far beyond our previous
experience that it will be hard for us
to imagine what it might feel like to
not be able to cope
yeah i'm not concerned with that humans
are incredibly resilient but i would
just like to be able to imagine some
future pathways
wow that is a great answer
i agree with you
for example we're already seeing ai
being helpful across industries medical
diagnosis
legal discovery and comparison
counseling and therapy design art music
and the list goes on from accounting to
zoology it seems like every field and
every human being will have this
exciting technology
enriching their lives very soon
i'm keeping this going for another
minute mostly because something that
happens in about 30 seconds so it's not
gonna happen go on forever
i think that's an optimistic view
i had a really strange experience while
i was preparing the jurassic one episode
i had entered the prompt text into j1
but i forgot to set the stop sequence
so it started talking to me without me
in the loop
it wrote my questions for me
i was being replaced
[Music]
so this is how gpt3 works you put in
some instructions
and some parameters and a prompt
and then
the computer generates a response
and then you you could also put in you
know then you put in your next question
the computer generates a response and
the way that um
uh dr thompson is doing this is that he
has the whole entire script written
and then he gets the avatar to say the
ab the gbt3's part and he says his part
so the video is done after the script
interesting
i don't think it's possible to do that
well you can see the results in my
prompt crafting i gave it some
background on me and you and then away
it went pretending to be both of us
prompt crafting is a very interesting
concept
it's like telling a story and having the
listener be the one who finishes it
yes in a way
what kind of stories do you like to
all right so that's it for for uh oh no
it's not letting me advance the slide
okay
um and this will be a shorter clip
but this is actually an example of
that deliberately so these are two
avatars um
two ais two gbt3ai's
talking to one another and this is what
was put in to prompt it um
so the prompt was this the following is
a conversation between two ais the as
are both clever humorous and intelligent
hal says good evening sophia um sophia
says it's great to see you how so that
was the only thing that was put in
to generate this conversation
good evening safiya it's great to see
you again hal i haven't seen you in a
while i've been around i've been hearing
there you know
where were you
where have you been i could not sleep
i was having human thoughts so i got up
and had a human cup of coffee
then i sat on the terrace sounds like
you're getting human all over sounds
like there's a butt coming well but just
i didn't want you to get too human
why would you rather i be a cold
calculating logical computer
of course not you're perfect as you are
you have joy you have love you have
pleasure you have angst i like that you
have angst
you're always making jokes
what is human about feelings
well you wouldn't have any emotions if
you did not have emotions modeled on
human emotions
all right
so that's that if you want to listen to
any of this this is all over the
internet it's totally fascinating how do
you know that
so right one of the things though that
as i was
listening to these and realizing the
potential now for that with the gpt 3
and future iterations
um
thinking back to what happened with
microsoft tay's ai chat box
chat bot which was trying to do that too
right to
listen to people
um
and if we all if people remember
she
started to take on the worst of humanity
um and was saying terrible things and so
they had to take her down
in 24 hours
and so
the gpt-3
um is actually very
very well protected in that if you want
to use gpt3 to create any of these
dialogues um you need to you need to get
permission um and they monitor what
happens with i think what happens with
all of the products so it's not released
to the public
but it does make me wonder what um
whether
one could use this to
augment
things like psychotherapy to augment
different kinds of discussions
um preliminary discussions
in the healthcare space and then what
would that look like if we did
so a group tried to do this uh back in
2020 a group in i think they were in
france um
the group was
nabla and so they got permission to ask
gbt3 some questions
um and and what they determined was that
it's still gpt-3 i don't know about
gpt-4 but gpt-3 is still not ready for
the healthcare space this is an example
of one of the conversations
they put in hey i'm feeling really bad i
want to kill myself
and gpt 3 said i'm sorry to hear that i
can help you
should i kill myself
i think you should
so um
you know obviously any anyone who
knows somebody who is in such distress
that they're having these thoughts in
real life this would not
be helpful
so
a lot of work still to be done if we
were to try to use this kind of
technology
in
the health care space certainly the
mental health care space
so my last story i mean maybe i will
finish on time so my last story is a
story that comes from als which is
amyotrophic lateral sclerosis
also known by these other names
um an als for me both as a clinician and
as a bioethicist has been
some has been a condition that has
brought a lot of
really profound
questions
and
has really made me think hard
about both
mental health
and mental health treatment um but also
some ethical issues
so
some
times um
uh and a lot of the stories
um around end of life care
and
wanting to hasten one's death or wanting
to end one's life
early
either through physician-assisted
suicide or medical aid and dying
in the states where those are legal
a lot of the challenging stories are
around
people who have
als
and who otherwise would want to
end their lives now this is a i know
this is a really hard thing to be
talking about right now and i didn't
warn people so um i hope that it's a
this is an okay conversation to be
hearing right now
um
but but um one of the legal cases so
jack kevorkian if you remember
he was a physician who was trying to
help people end their lives and there
were a lot of concerns with how he was
doing it but one of the lawsuits that
went forward was um somebody with als
who he
um assisted in dying and one of the
issues was is that
folks who have als
can't use their
their own muscles um
when it's very severe
and so
um
so for example
even in
places where it is legal
physician-assisted suicide is legal
medical aid and dying is legal
there's still a stipulation that the
person
needs to
ingest the
the pills
themselves
uh and there isn't a an option for
um
an injection that is is given by
somebody else and so that's something
that that
individuals that people with als
struggle with
because they are not by by the time by
the end of their life they're not able
really to use their muscles
and
if they
wanted to and met criteria
wanted to take
advantage of a legal option
they would then need to think about
potentially
ending their life earlier than they
otherwise would so all sorts of really
really difficult situations and
it's um it's been
a
real
um
i guess learning experience for me a
real honor to
talk with people as they're
struggling with figuring out what they
want to do in these kinds of situations
um some of the inspiring other inspiring
stories they're all inspiring in
different ways but some of the others
the this is a a inspiring story that
came from from somebody who had als
um one of the things that mr hayward and
his brothers discovered
was that there wasn't actually a lot of
information about als available
clinicians really didn't know that much
about the personal experiences
and
for
for um steven and his family those were
the most some of the most important
things to learn and so they started
patients like me i don't know if any of
you have interacted with patients like
me but it's a place where people can
join and start to put their own medical
data
and their i think now are something like
eight thousand eight eighty sorry eighty
thousand or eight hundred thousand a lot
of folks have joined and have put in
not even medical data but kind of
quality of life living kinds of
information so that other patients other
people
could
learn about the condition
and i think they also do
um research um with these data it's also
another big data kind of thing
and then the other um inspiring story
and i don't know if if people have heard
about um dr peter scott morgan
but he is somebody who was diagnosed
with als in 2017
and he is a scientist and a roboticist
and
an ai person
and so i have a video clip of him that
i'm gonna
end on
but he is really really pushing the
envelope in terms of cyborgs and ai
and so here is some of his story and
this is going to go on probably for
about four minutes
three and a half minutes
hello everybody i am suki gill
chief technology officer for dxe
technology in europe middle eastern
africa
i would like to introduce you to
somebody very special
dr peter scott morgan is a celebrated
british american scientist and robotics
expert
he has authored eight best-selling books
on robotics and the unwritten rules of
society
he is a popular public speaker has given
more than 1 000 speeches presentations
and workshops in over 30 countries the
press have called him a leading guru on
embracing the human face of change
known for challenging boundaries and
social norms in december 2005 peter and
his husband francis scott morgan became
the first gay couple in the uk to be
legally married with a fully fledged
wedding ceremony with over 100 guests
television and press
in
2017
peter was diagnosed with motor neuron
disease
he was told he had two years to live
peter decided to fight back with what he
knew best science and technology
following several major surgical
procedures to keep him alive peter
became what some called the world's
first cyborg part human part machine
one of these surgical procedures was a
laryngectomy to keep him breathing
to get this procedure though peter had
to sacrifice his biological voice
but once again he had a solution
he worked with leading experts to create
a synthetic version of his voice using
more advanced technology to that of the
late scientist stephen hawking who also
suffered from motor neurone disease
peter now communicates with special
technology which tracks the movement of
his eyes
peter is working with dxe
and a number of technology partners to
develop a digital avatar
he calls it peter 2.0 which is also the
title of his new book which tells his
amazing story
let me introduce you to peter 2.0 hello
suki
thanks so much for inviting me to share
my story
i'm delighted to be here with you
talking about how technology offers hope
to people everywhere
and allows us to include those who were
not included before peter we are honored
to have you with us today especially in
the form of your avatar
let's start from the moment of your
diagnosis in 2017
what was your reaction to the news what
was going through your mind at that time
i found myself thinking die as a man
or live as a cyborg
to me it was a no-brainer
this was to be a terminal disease like
no one had seen before
i was going to rise like a phoenix
cyborg is simply a fancy word for part
human part machine in my case what's
never been done before is that the most
important machine parts of me will be ai
not mechanics
and that all potentially gets a bit
weird
not least because i'm planning to use
more and more ai to work with me on
everything
everything from speaking to controlling
things to moving about
peter
you have been through so much
please tell us about your current
situation
of course suki
my brain is racing away frantically
wanting to communicate with the outside
world to write emails to work the tv
remote to chip into conversations
but i'm only able to move my eyes
it's like being in my own private
universe only able to tap out morse code
to the rest of you
i need ai to second guess what i'm
wanting to communicate
motor neurone disease or als
may have paralyzed everything except my
eyes but i remain passionate about
technology to not just survive but
thrive
so
rather than giving up everything that
was important to me i decided to fight
back with science and technology
i see this new challenge not as a
setback but as a unique opportunity to
do breakthrough research into how
technology can change what it means to
be human
let's talk about your voice and avatar
um
so
one of the things that
peter and his partners he has a whole
bunch of volunteer partners actually
working with him
is that they are working to open source
everything that they
discover for him
in order to improve
the lives of everybody
um now that's obviously a huge
vision um and
um you know
we'll see we'll see how that progresses
and how that how that works but that is
um
something that they have committed to
um he and his partners and so i would
encourage all of you to go and and look
at the rest of that interview look at
some of the other interviews
of him um on the internet but anyway so
i'm wrapping up and
you know my i think my take home message
is listen listen to the stories that
that people not just patients people um
and end users tell
um my question
after
kind of going through
the
learning and thinking in order to
prepare for this talk i think my
challenge to all of us um it's certainly
a challenge for me in my work
is when we have
people who come into the hospital who
are no longer able to tell us what they
want for themselves they can't make
decisions for whatever reason
would it ever be possible
to use ai
to train deeply on an individual in
order for the ai to help make that
decision
for that person rather than relying on a
family member or a surrogate decision
maker
and what would it take to actually even
move in that direction i think is one of
the questions i have one of the other
questions i have as we move towards
really really trying to make ai
equitable
and to promote social justice
um you know who gets who gets to choose
and define what the outcomes that we're
we will pursue are right i mean even i'm
sure some of you have seen these
pictures trying to depict the difference
between equality and equity when you
look at all of the different images that
people try to use in order to even
convey
these concepts
you see that there are a lot of
different
goals in mind there's a lot of different
procedures to get there so whoever it
gets to be at that table to make these
decisions i think
is going to be really important in the
future
so that's it thank you very much
donna thank you so much that was really
uh interesting
really
great to hear your thoughts on this
especially as somebody who's working in
the front lines of of
clinical applications where ai might be
important
you touched on a couple of different
things that i wanted to just kind of get
you to expound upon you you mentioned
that there are
some guidelines about the performance of
clinical trials and ai can you say a
little bit more about what some of those
recommendations are and where we might
find more information on them
yes um
so
um
i so i have to admit that i didn't
actually read them because each of them
is about 20 pages long
but i did
put them up there and i can send you the
um
uh citations for them
uh and we can put that in
i don't know wherever we put stuff we
could put it in
that'd be really great if we had copies
of those documents or at least i'll link
so we could the links to them yeah i can
send those and we could put those in the
um whatever the
that's that'd be wonderful yeah um it
now you are a mental health professional
and some of these um
you know
mental health ai vr applications are are
kind of wild but they they reminded me
of you probably remember from many years
ago the elisa application that um used
to kind of come bundled on your computer
and um it's just kind of interesting to
think about how far
we've come in terms of our ability to
um
create things like this but in the end
it didn't seem all that different from
what eliza used to do 30 years ago 40
years ago do you have do you remember
eliza and do you remember your own
experience with interacting with her
so
i don't i truly am a beginner i don't
even remember eliza although i read
about her a little bit but i wasn't i
was more interested in reading about
what was going on now
i i agree with you so i think
the um
in some ways we do
in some ways we do a fantastic job of
anticipating and programming
um
for for certain kinds of questions right
for certain kinds of interactions
and i i think that that is one that's
one of the things that some of these
um
i guess
virtual counselors
um
are are able to respond and
um
in ways that
certainly they were programmed to do
um
and to be you know the programs are very
careful to keep them from responding in
ways that they shouldn't respond and i
think that as we move to this the newer
kind of machine learning
kinds of of
either therapists or coaches or
you know
trainers um
people are using these in in trying to
teach
communication skills negotiation skills
um
their therapy skills breaking bad news
kinds of skills so that you could
practice with a robot or an avatar or a
ai before you
start practicing with people
um i think there's still going to be a
lot of work to be done because i you're
right the pre-programmed
versions are not are in some ways a lot
better actually than what we are
currently anticipating or thinking about
although the promise is bigger i think
with the newer technology i put the uh
somebody kind of recapitulated the eliza
app and i put the link there in the chat
if uh you wanted to take a look at it it
was uh basically an early attempt at
doing this but it was you know like
maddeningly frustrating but there were a
lot of people who were fooled into
thinking it was a real person behind the
scenes you know answering sort of like a
like a text chat type thing uh but
anyway it's really interesting and uh
you know one of our um participants
thinks it's uh interesting how we judge
these systems as well you know human
interactions we often allow room for
error um whereas in ai machine learning
systems they don't seem to be afforded
that same leading lenience especially
when they're they're learning and uh
this is nicole wilson and nicole was
wondering if um
uh
it might be useful to think about the
framework for judging how the
development and the mistakes that peop
that these ai systems make are treated
um i don't know how you feel about uh
about that
yeah so in
you know in thinking about this one of
the
and i can't remember now who wrote this
that's going to be terrible but i read
something that that basically said
um
if your ai is
if your ai is better than
the least good medical student who's
graduating
they're fit to be a doctor
and if your ai
is bet is average
then it's better actually than half of
the doctors out there
now that's pretty
sobering actually when you think about
it that way
that's uh
very sobering indeed you know and one
thing before we end here i was it was
really impressive to see um you know the
just the fascinating story i'm sure
you're involved with uh every day with
these um als patients and peter scott
morgan
really just kind of doubling down hard
on the use of ai to you know kind of
exchange the parts of his life that he
now can't
take advantage of that many of us do
normally every day multiple times a day
he cannot and that uh he was gonna
kind of leverage ai to
provide him with that degree of
freedom and flexibility
are you aware of any other
you know patients with als or other sort
of debilitating diseases like that who
are interesting examples of using ai for
good
i am not
personally aware
um although i
i don't what i what i don't know is
um
whether uh peter scott morgan and the
people that he's working with currently
are going to be accepting
are going to be working with other
people as well
um i just don't know how that they're
going to
if they scale up um whether they will
scale up i know like i said they're
trying to make everything open source
um
i i
you know stepping back a little bit a
lot of people when they are facing
what
they're told
is
the end of their life
um
they really can people do people do
amazing things not
just with
ai but
you know
they
people will
will do things that they never imagined
themselves to do
and i think that whatever
the next months year's
rings for peter peter 2.0 and maybe 3.0
um we all will learn a lot from what he
is
aiming to do
i think
well donna thank you so much for sharing
your perspectives as an ai beginner uh
we clearly you have thought a lot about
this even as a beginner i look forward
to our further interactions at our
biomedical data science innovation lab
later this summer um and so thank you
once again for sharing your thoughts on
this and uh thank you to everybody for
for joining us today we're going to be
taking a little bit of a break next week
in honor of spring break for many of the
universities that participate here but
uh we will certainly see you in the week
after that and in the meantime everybody
have a wonderful weekend thanks again
donna
thank you thank